Located in the middle of the Himalayas
in Nepal is one of the most isolated,
remote and poorest countries in the
world.
Traditionally,
it has been a kinds of protectorates or
satellites country for India.
However,
at the end of 2017,
the Communist Party of Nepal won the
elections with an overwhelming majority
and they've now set their sights on
Beijing.
In this video,
we're going to show you what is
happening as a bit about this country's
greatest hidden treasure.
So let's get into it.
Alright,
so I've got a question for you and
please don't Google the answer.
That would be cheating.
Do you know which country Buddha was
born in?
One,
two,
three.
Probably.
Guess it's Nepal,
the country located in the Himalayas,
which hosts many of the highest
mountains in the world,
specifically in this country,
which covers an area about the size of
Nicaragua.
We can find eight out of the 14 summits
in the entire world,
the reach more than 8,000
meters,
and this includes,
of course,
Mount Everest becomes very also boasts a
total of 240 pigs that reach higher than
6,000
meters.
In other words,
Nepal is a absolute paradise for people
who love mountains,
and by the way Katmandu,
it's capital ends,
the largest city in the Himalayas is
also one of backpack.
His favorite cities on the planet and
well,
why is that?
Yes,
well,
maybe it does something to do with the
fact that this city is full of temples,
pagodas and Ali's full of life,
like hobbies or were in the 21st
century.
You won't be able to find skyscrapers
wide avenues,
modern buses or practically any luxury
franchise.
Yes,
it's pretty cool,
right?
Like one of those last drops of history
in a totally modern and global world.
Well,
as wonderful as it sounds for a visit,
the reality is that Nepal is one of the
poorest countries in the world.
According to the United Nations.
Nepal is one of the Asian countries with
the worst human development index.
Scores in Nepal comes in at 144th in
that ranking bands.
I'll be honest,
this isn't really surprising.
See,
despite having almost 30 million
inhabitants,
it's economy is smaller than that of
Bolivia whose population belly exceeds
10 million people.
That means that in per capita terms,
Bolivia is three times richer than
Nepal.
That's why with everyday that passes
1,500
people move abroad,
people.
And if you are,
this has not made it easy for the
Nepalese.
Do you want to know why?
Well,
listen up dominated country.
Yeah.
The political system has been anchored
in the past until practically the day
before yesterday in 2008.
Nepal was an absolute monarchy under the
exclusive control of the king and by the
way,
fun little tidbit of knowledge right now
despite being the birth place of butter
itself,
until 2006,
this was the only country in the world
were hidden.
Do Islam was the official religion,
but also leave that between 1996 and
2006.
The country suffered through a civil war
between governments or forces,
the monarchy,
dictatorship forces and the Maoist
rebels who supported the establishment
of a communist republic.
Yes.
You heard that right?
Monarchy,
civil war Maoism probably can understand
now why this country is quite so poor.
There has been such a huge amounts of
chaos in the last 30 years,
but the average life expectancy of a
government was wait for it one year.
You have you.
That is certainly not everything.
Nepal has another characteristic that is
greatly conditioned.
It's political and economic situation.
See as you probably known,
Nepal has no coast and have you noticed
too all that only neighbors exactly in
Nepal is stuck between two giants
between the two most probable future
great powers of this century.
Of course,
that's India and that's China to
countries that Maura,
that don't exactly get on very well as
we have seen previously on visual
politic.
Yes,
we could say that both China and India
are in the forefront of Nepal's.
Ministry of Foreign Affairs mind.
Well,
the fact is that traditionally,
and largely thanks to the geography that
favors at Nepal has been kind of a
satellite country for India,
something the New Delhi government has
always been very,
very clear about
wants to micromanage Nepal.
They have to control all government
appointments.
They have to know everything.
They're ambassadors behave like
viceroys,
aren't we?
A sovereign nation,
Kishore Shrestha,
editor of Jonah Asta National Weekly and
a board member of Nepal's press council.
Perhaps the best proof of how India has
always wanted to control this remote
countries.
Destiny happens in 2015,
but that's the only political forces
were designing the constitution of the
newly created Democratic Federal
Republic of the poll.
Well,
New Delhi demanded that Nepal create a
separate province for people of Indian
descent who were living in the terrain
planes say region in southern Nepal on
the border with.
Yeah.
This was something that the Nepalese
political forces emphatically opposed.
They wouldn't established political
separations based on identity under any
circumstances.
Well,
when New Delhi didn't get an affirmative
answer,
what do you think they did?
Well,
they blocked the borders.
Now it was all but provision trucks,
they just stopped crossing.
Now,
this would have been bad,
really,
really bad under any circumstances,
but on top of all of that,
this blockade happens when the country
was at its worst,
it adjusts,
suffered a huge wake quake that caused
enormous damage.
The deadly's seven point eight magnitude
earthquake struck Nepal in 2015 and
killed thousands of people so powerful.
It moved Mount Everest is he not want.
This hasn't been the only blockade or
the only strategy that India is used to
pressure the Nepalese politicians to
follow their advice offer.
All trade with India has traditionally
accounted for almost three quarters of
all Napoli's trade,
the now after centuries of absolute
monarchy and decades of war and chaos.
Things are finally beginning to
normalize in the polk and democracy is
gaining strength and also China's doors
that are getting to open China's
arrival.
Okay?
China and Nepal share a 1,400
kilometer border and in recent years,
this border,
it's become quite fashionable.
Commercial relations between both
countries have tripled since 2010 China
results.
It becomes the country.
This invests the most money every year
in Nepal and tourism coming from the
great Asian power is growing rapidly in
the last 10 years alone,
despite the earthquake,
the number of Chinese tourists arriving
into poll every year has multiplied by
four
present trying to depaul relations are
developing at the fastest pace.
We've seen you home Chinese ambassador
in Nepal.
That's how relations between Nepal and
China are growing.
Hydro power to cement Chinese businesses
are already all around this small South
Asian country.
Chinese Internet providers are breaking
Indian monopoly.
Chinese tourists are flooding Nepal.
Chinese language institutions are
mushrooming more Nepali students are
traveling to China and to India and
hundreds of Nepali officers are invited
to China every year as part of an
unprecedented charm offensive that's not
all.
At the end of 2017 elections were held
to elect a new parliaments and two brand
new government.
The communist party's victory was
overwhelming and this is a communist
party.
Very much influenced by Beijing.
Now the new prime minister Cardigan
really has boosted relations with its
northern neighbor to grow trade and
investments,
but also to gain independence from India
because it's number one priority and
folks,
Beijing clearly doesn't want to miss
this opportunity.
Therefore,
Beijing is putting huge projects on the
table to change the whole situation
forever.
Roads,
airports,
and the bubble,
the promise of a new railway line.
Appreciate because sign up with a other
fields.
For example,
the Chinese government has announced
that is looking into extending the
railway that connects to best with the
eastern coast all the way to the
Nepalese border and there is little
doubt that China would have no problem
financing the railways construction all
the way to cat.
Man Do.
Okay.
By the way,
we already know talking about a small
project APP,
connecting Napoleon.
China by rail could mean multiplying the
arrival of Chinese tourists by 10,
15 or even 20 times.
And if the train in addition was
connected to the Indian railway network,
we could be speaking of a revolution in
transporting merchandise between the
two.
Great giant.
If we can connect this railway network,
our east West Rail project,
it can revolutionize trying to India
trade with Nepal in the Middle Cod,
God prawsaud,
Prime Minister of Nepal.
Of course the new government doesn't
intend to break ties with India,
but it looks like Nepal has stopped
being New Delhi subordinates and most
importantly for the first time it looks
like this country has a clear option for
a better future.
You want to know our well,
listen up future water and mountains.
Nepal is one of the poorest countries in
the world,
but it doesn't have to continue to be
so.
Allow me to explain.
On the one hand in Nepal is a country
with nature,
mountains,
exotic landscapes,
and an impressive gastronomy.
I mean,
there's no secret that it's tourism
potential is absolutely huge,
especially if communications with China
improve and just we've seen that's
pretty damn likely to happen.
I mean,
who would not like to visit Nepal?
It's not all in fact,
far from it.
The Paul's great hidden treasure is
actually water.
Yep.
You heard that right?
It's really water as we've already seen.
The pool has huge mountains and steep
valleys that have been carved by large
rivets and what can be done with all of
this natural wealth.
Wow.
Studies conducted by the Nepalese
government and show them the pools of
underwater resources can produce huge
amounts of hydroelectric power at a very
low cost.
Basically it's potential power
generation capacity could be almost 50
percent,
half of all the hydro power that is
produced within the United States,
and
that is a lot of electricity.
Now,
let's not forget,
Nepal is located between India and China
and very close to Bangladesh.
These all three fast growing economies
whose electricity consumption is
absolutely soaring and the pool,
while that may have the capacity to
supply them with the cheapest
electricity of all.
Now,
of course so far,
none of this has been exploited,
but everything indicates that this
abandonments can be left behind very
quickly.
If the country regain stability,
investors will line up to finance and
develop this kind of project.
The only resource we have,
like the Arabian countries,
have oil is water chubby guy or project
manager at the rush of what God.
The hydroelectric project,
a 111 megawatt plant under construction
near China's border and the potential it
doesn't end there.
Nepal's new closeness to China could
make Chinese money Russians to the
country in order to finance large
hydroelectric plants.
Well,
that's precisely what the Nepalese
government is thinking.
Depaul's new communist prime minister
will restart a Chinese led two point $5,
billion US dollar hydropower project
that was pulled by the previous
government,
considered friendly towards India.
Anyway,
the situation now is that the pool is
still a very poor country,
but with new policies it could stop
being so.
So will the new government,
the able to leave its ideological
inclinations behind and bet on
stability,
openness and foreign investments?
Well,
only time will tell,
but now it's your turn.
Do you think that Nepal should bet on
China or should it continue to
strengthen ties with India?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoy this video.
Please hit like if you did and do not
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.